[Music]
you know you looking at you looking at
me we think the same things I want to
take
seriously
oh don't want to dance alone so come
here with me you made a glov I made a
stone one more thing to say before you
go I don't talk a talk
a so you should listen
[Applause]
me
all it's all you know I love you
do I love you
too I love you
too I love you too
you know I you too not you me not only
you we're here forever how does it feel
knowing the truth
oh don't to dance alone so come here
with me you're in the class all your
own one more thing I've got to let you
know I don't talk a lot
talk so you should listen up me what I
say
I
all it's all okay you know I love you
too I love you
too I love you too you know you too you
know I never really thought about how it
feels to say these words
L it's so
weird but it's true and take you what
even think about how it feels when you
were not
around I want to stay here cuz I love
you
[Applause]
[Music]
to
[Applause]
I don't talkot talk
aot so you should listen up I mean what
I
say I'm
not
afraid it's okay you know I love you
too I like you
too I like you too
you know I love you
too I love you
too I love you too you know I love you
[Music]
too
hey there friends this is my friend
Mufasa he did the amazing camera work in
that video Mufasa working the good
people find you on social media you can
find me at fgam Mona on Instagram and
sometimes on YouTube nowadays
outstanding thank you so much for
helping me out of course happy holidays
everybody hey friends I hope you enjoyed
that bit of flow to the always fabulous
Charlie
XCX um real quickly I just want to put
out a huge thank you to flow toys for
sponsoring this video and giving me a
reason to go out and get down with one
of my favorite pop stars if you'd like
to grab a set of those flow moja LED
contact po that I was using in this
video you can do so by using the code
Drex Factor noov
2023 over at checkout at flowtoys.com
that is drexfactor noov 2023 yes we had
to change the code a little early this
month but that code will work until
December 1st so get in those Black
Friday uh orders off of that code thank
you very much and thank you again to
flow toys for making it possible for me
to get out and explore some flow in
DC speaking of thank yous um I owe some
thanks to the Friends of the channel big
thanks to dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys juggling calling pyroar
light toys spinballs and Ultra poy for
making the videos on this channel
possible you can learn more about all
these amazing companies and the work
that they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
out the links that I've got down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non- bus friend of the
channel That is beeka Bean thank you so
very much for supporting my channel my
work and my mission finally the videos
on this channel would not be possible
without my wonderful patreon supporters
in particular I would like to give a
shout out to my flow patrons who are
listed on screen right now uh if you'd
like to check out more of my flow videos
I will include a link to a playlist of
those down in the description as well as
a link to my P patreon if he would like
to sign up to support the channel thanks
so much for watching make sure to get
out and flow today and I'll see you with
a new video real soon Happy Thanksgiving
if you live in the US and I will see you
the new video real soon peace